um but these wives typically kind of get
into some weird later they're very
attention addicted they tend to be
failed actresses um I I kind of I see
kind of Steph Curry's wife is the same
sort of archetype and you know they get
older and they just start engaging in
some weird um you know with with
Jada was like the open relationship but
you start to see these women where maybe
when they were younger they had a higher
sexual market value you than their
husbands when the attention is starting
to go they just start to go nuts they
start to go crazy insane what the The
Telltale sign of these wives is their
husbands typically put them on a
pedestal so I I see Steve Harvey's wife
Margery kind of the same way